damaged but not destroyed the chonga
bridge-linking Crimea and Harrison
province in southern Ukraine it's one of
the roots Russian forces used to move
between Crimea annexed by Russia in 2014
and other parts of Ukraine under
Russia's control
russian-appointed officials say the
bridge was hit by a type of long-range
missile that France and the UK have
given Ukraine's military
is another meaningless act perpetrated
by the key for regime on orders from
London it solves nothing as far as the
special military operation is concerned
officials in Crimea say repairing the
damage could take several weeks in
Moscow President Vladimir Putin was at
the Tomb of the Unknown Soldier
commemorating the anniversary of the
Nazi invasion of the Soviet Union he
also chaired a session of the National
Security Council
here defense minister Sergey shoigu
tells him Ukrainian forces are
decreasing their activity on the front
line and regrouping but could still
Mount offensive actions
indeed it looks like the Ukraine's
Western allies decided to fight Russia
till the last Ukrainian however we must
assume that the enemy's offensive
potential has not been exhausted yet a
number of strategic reserves have not
been deployed
shipment
Ukraine's counter-offensive began in the
southern region of zaporizia earlier
this month but in the words of President
zielinski progress has been slower than
desired in this video released on
Thursday he claims Ukraine's
intelligence Services have information
that Russia's planning an incident to
release radiation from the zapparesia
nuclear power plant the largest in
Europe
there should never be any terrorist
attacks on nuclear power plants anywhere
this time it should not be like with
kakovka the world has been warned so the
world can it must act the kremlins
dismiss the allegation as another lie
this week Ukraine's Military
Intelligence Chief accused Russia of
mining the cooling pond that's used to
keep the reactors cool
oh
Ukrainian troops have fired on the front
line near Russian occupied Donetsk in
recent days but there's nothing to
suggest either side making any real
gains here or elsewhere Nadeem Barber Al
Jazeera